Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
Ruffians!
Are you awake?
Yeah, you're awake?
Good morning!
Thank you Ruffians for waking us- Waking us up?
Waking up and joining us for our 131st episode today!
FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-FUWA-F
Do you know what the next part is?
Moco-chan.
I'm asking them!
Huh?
BAU BAU.
Not left paw.
Is that a hashtag?
No, that's not the FWMCMORNING information!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
What's the hashtag?
I forgot, Moco-chan.
Use the hashtag.
Yes!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's uh... Fill in the blank.
This is the FUWAMOCO Morning.
We get the Ruffians to answer.
Let's uh...
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
That was much easier than usual, Hamoco-chan.
Yeah, because the Ruffians helped us out, right?
They'd be stuck otherwise.
Really?
I don't think so.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
We hope that it hasn't been too rough of a weekend.
It's gonna be a really fun weekend too!
I'm ready Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
But first!
Disappointment!
Disappointment?
I don't want anymore of that.
Disappointment time.
Guys!
There's been another Pero Sighting.
Where was he seen this time, Moco-chan?
Is there anything we can do to stop it?
Well, I don't think there's anything we can do to stop it because it's important to know, but let's take a look.
Oh!
This is a great Pero Sighting!
Yeah!
Yeah?
Right!
No nasty Pero in view at all!
Right?
It's just a beautiful little place in Italy!
Right!
Well, I don't know.
I don't think Pero would ever be caught in a place like this, right?
I don't know.
Right?
Do you want to live in Pero?
I'm sure Pero is a beautiful place, but maybe he's visiting.
Yeah.
I don't know, maybe he could be hanging out somewhere else instead.
Maybe.
How about BAU BAU in Indonesia?
I feel like it'd be strange if you know.
It'd be easy to be quiet if you're in a place that is your name, you know?
Why not?
Yeah... It's not his city!
But, BAU BAU, I'd like to visit BAU BAU!
Yeah, I think I'd too!
Yeah, but only if Pero isn't there.
True.
Yeah... We're not going searching for him, okay?
Don't misunderstand!
Yeah, you know, if Pero's there, it's gonna be nasty.
I wanna see BAU BAU at it's most beautiful!
Yeah!
Yeah... As you know, I got a BAU BAU.
And then... You know what we do next?
Wait, BAU BAU wants some BAU BAU!
BAU BAU wants!
I quit!
I don't know what to say!
But then you're scared of maybe saying the same thing as me at the same time?
I understand that feeling, huh?
Yeah, we couldn't do that, huh?
No.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, it's funny how Pero is shaped like Pero, though.
I think it would be.
It's good like that.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
It's a new month and that means there's a new voice pack!
We have the Halloween voice pack!
It is October after all.
And this time it's Halloween with villains.
Villains.
Yeah, FUWAMOCO.
You know, we're both FUWAMOCO, but this time we're a little bit evil.
Maybe just a tiny bit.
Ruffians, have you had a chance to check the Melody Unit?
If you haven't, please go over to the official hololive shop.
There's some voice previews that you can check out.
And maybe you can check out just how evil FUWAMOCO has become.
Elizabeth is a villain!
We're all villains!
Yeah.
It's not evil, it's just cute.
Fuwawa's as evil as usual.
Are you saying that I'm evil all the time?
Are you saying that I'm not very evil when I'm supposed to be evil?
I'm a villain.
What about Mococo?
BAU BAU.
Yeah.
Hopefully it'll put you in a spooky
And a fluffy and fuzzy mood!
Yo!
Yeah!
Yeah, but I think you know it's definitely a little less scary than the extreme love voice part.
Right.
So, if you want a cute and a unique way to celebrate Halloween, we recommend it!
You know, this time it's extra silly.
Ruffians, you know how much we love pon-de-rings.
And now too, you know when there's something that we love, we want you to love it too.
This time I especially
What you are pondering the door is lots and lots and lots and lots and lots and lots and lots and lots.
I'm doing my best to be evil.
So I need your support.
Got it!
So please go have a listen!
You know, it's a nice way to get in the Halloween mood.
Especially early on in this month, or maybe you want to save it until later.
Putting extra special video maybe on Halloween night as well.
Please check it out, okay?
BAU BAU!
And next!
Well, there's been a lot of exciting big things happening in hololive English, but another one just happened!
40 Senpai, she's hit a huge, huge, huge milestone!
She just reached 1 million subscribers on YouTube!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations!
FUWAMOCO!
That's pretty cool!
I can't wait to see what she's gonna do today!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Just a few more pages and that'll be 1 million pages.
Right!
That's amazing!
Amazing!
Yeah!
You can really feel all the love!
But again, congratulations!
Congratulations!
I feel like I wanna almost get cronies sent by headpats too.
Or a hug.
Yeah.
And then she can give us a massage.
Moco-chan, you're just thinking of more massages!
I was just thinking, after a hug, maybe it'll be nice.
BAU BAU!
I see some Ruffians here.
FUWAMOCO, you may be getting close to... We're doing our best!
I don't know Ruffians!
Let's do our best!
And let's have a lot of fun until maybe it's our turn for a big milestone.
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
There's some other big things happening too.
And you know, something that we really really like and always look forward to.
We have some senpai with some 3D lives coming out!
Well, the clock just turned midnight in Japan, which means it's officially Fubuki-senpai's birthday now!
BAU BAU!
And to celebrate it, Fubuki-senpai is having a birthday party live entitled
Fubu Kingdom!
Prologue!
Yes!
And it's on the 5th!
At 5AMP- 4AM!
4AMPT!
Yes!
4AMPT or 8PM GST.
And the theme is FUBU KINGDOM!
Nice!
I'm wondering just what kind of kingdom it's gonna be.
Very nice.
What kind of kingdom will she be showing us around in?
What kind of friends will be there waiting for us, huh?
Definitely the best.
Happy birthday FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO!
So that's really soon, so check it out, okay?
Really soon, yeah!
But shortly after that, FUWAMOCO will be having her 4th anniversary 3D Lifetime Mirage!
Mirage!
Yeah, sound extra special.
And that's gonna be on the 5th at 5PM KT, about 12 hours difference, right?
Or the 6th at 9AM JST!
Very very soon too!
Yeah, very soon, you know.
Shiori-senpai just kind of shared some of the guest stuff.
Maybe a bit of a sample.
I know there's some horns there.
Yeah, I think Nerissa mentioned that she's gonna be one of the guests here at Kiara-senpai's live here.
Yeah, so you'll have to make sure to set your clothes ready to check out what kind of mirage Kiara-senpai has waiting for us.
What could they sing?
They could sing so many things together!
I'm so excited!
Yay!
Good for Nerissa!
And a happy 4th anniversary to Kiara-senpai!
Yay!
But!
That's not it!
Let's not just stop there!
Let's not wait!
Stop!
FUWAMOCO's hololive ID we have already set!
Yay!
It's gonna be her birthday live too!
Her very first CD birthday live!
I can't believe it!
Yeah!
She's also gonna be showcasing her new 3D outfit that she used her million wish on!
Really?
Yeah right!
That's crazy!
And there'll be other friends joining her as well. So I'm really excited. It's not gonna be too long until then too so. Let's look forward to it and make sure you know. That we're there to support all our senpais.
Yay
You know how big a birthday 3D Live is?
It's a really big deal!
It's a big deal, okay?
Lots of process and hard work goes into it.
Yes!
We really hope that you'll be there to support everybody and to celebrate, you know, whether it's their birthday, anniversary, or just, you know, another day.
It's a big celebration!
A big 3D Live!
I'm so excited.
I wanna be able to see how they're gonna perform.
Yeah!
What kind of always so much new outfit?
Why excited?
Rebirth?
Huh?
What kind of always so much new outfit?
She's enjoying me!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, exciting, right?
We have lots of great stuff coming up.
But it doesn't just stop there!
We have Biboo!
hololive English -Advent- aura.
Beautiful sparkling gem.
Koseki Bijou.
She's been kind of teasing something over on her Twitter.
And I think it's something really big.
Look here, Ruffians!
What and who are all these magical girls here?
Who could it be?
Green, blue, dark blue, purple, pink, orange, yellow.
Like a rainbow.
Shiny.
Shiny, sparkly.
Pretty cute.
I don't know why.
It's not a salad.
No.
Salad?
It's not a salad.
It's at least a fruit bowl.
It's not delicious leaves, okay?
But Biboo, she's mentioning you know she's gonna be doing an archive karaoke stream on the 6th at 4pm PT.
And that will be leading into this big announcement!
At 6pm PT or 10am JST on the 7th.
So please be there!
Don't miss it, okay?
We're so excited, I can't wait!
Mococo must be hungry.
No.
Ruffians, I think that's your problem.
You still haven't had breakfast, okay?
Go have breakfast.
Go have fun.
Breakfast, okay, Ruffians?
Don't miss Biboo's big announcement!
BAU BAU!
Over on the JP side of things, Mikoji-senpai!
Just a few hours earlier she was doing a stream where she made a sheet of her family relationships to other hololive members!
Let's take a look!
FUWAMOCO!
We'll be her pets!
Yes!
We're demon dogs!
We can't be Mikuchi-senpai's pets!
What's wrong with that?
It is Mikuchi-senpai time.
Hi.
I can be Mikocchi-senpai's pet.
Yes!
You know she said she'd scold us when we do bad things.
We do bad things, Ruffians!
We don't do bad things.
Bad things.
What?
She wouldn't say mad at us.
Oh my god.
Don't be scary and mad, Mikocchi-senpai.
Oh actually, what kind of bad things should we do?
I want to test her.
She talked about it, but I don't want to mention that yet.
We will do both kind of bad things.
No!
No.
We had a chill on Mikocchi-senpai.
What part should we chill on?
But you know, I sort of feel like her mom is part of the dog family. Dad's part of the dog family.
Ah
Shouldn't we be more like her little tiny sisters or something?
Why?
It looks like there's a lot of dogs in her family.
Yeah!
Or onee-chan!
You know, Korone-senpai!
Korone-senpai!
Huh?
Why is it dogs as her pets, huh?
Her parents are dogs, her sisters are dogs, and her pets are dogs.
Huh?
Something is fishy.
And doggy.
But you know, she also said that she wanted to clean out our ears!
Which works well!
Because we wanted to always get our ears cleaned professionally in Japan!
Yeah, that's what a lot of fathers and fathers... You know, it'd be exuberant, but... Getting them cleaned by Winkochi-san, but... Is that not unprofessional?
But, you know, Rikuchi-senpai's gonna clean our ears off, and that means... It doesn't count as touching the ears, okay?
Love pillow!
Take it!
Love pillow from Rikuchi-senpai.
It's not touching the ears, okay?
It's cleaning them.
It's different.
Cleaning is not touching.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
And I'm sure that she'll give us lots of pon-de-rings, right?
Treats!
Treats could be good, yeah!
BAU BAU!
We'll even send Mia for her, too.
Yeah!
Wouldn't that make us more cat-like?
Well, Mikocchi-senpai knows she'll give us good pon-de-rings.
Do not touch the ears!
Cleaning is different.
It's different.
Different touch.
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Also my Doggie of the Day!
Yo!
Let's check out today's Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Naichuu!
Wow!
What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a... What a...
Wow, and look there's a very happy looking eel coming on back there.
Yeah, I'm probably swishing back and forth.
You're not happy?
I'm happy!
You're just like any good Doggie of the Day.
A big cheek!
Yeah, the big cheek's the one that poked that, wasn't you?
Very, very cute.
Not bad, wasn't you?
No, no, no, no, no!
Yeah.
Very cute.
Very good Doggie of the Day.
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm BAU BAU.
BAU BAU.
FUWAMOCO!
It's a bit different.
You know there's lots of doggies out there.
FUWAMOCO.
FUWAMOCO loves to be chased around lots and lots until it gets all tuckered out and then loves to be carried.
Wow, what a baby.
I am FUWAMOCO!
Moco-chan, are we ready?
Are we ready to do that job?
FUWAMOCO!
Yeah!
You know we'll chase and chase FUWAMOCO and then I think you know we're gonna take him away forever.
Whatever!
Yum.
That was very cute, doggy!
Night tour!
Bye bye!
FUWAMOCO Abyss!
Even though the season's changing, it's getting a little bit cooler.
You're still getting those paws outside hitting the pavement, right?
Let's check out what we went on today!
I went on a walk!
We have... De-den!
The Aria Plus
Fubuki-senpai and Mio-senpai and your whole club!
We're so happy we're able to get out and enjoy the Aniplex cafe that's happening in Singapore right now!
There's so many exciting things going on in Singapore!
These club cafes are always such a bunch of fun!
And we hope that you had a really good time.
Maybe you're able to get your paws on some treasure too.
I'd say it's a very successful walk there.
Meet with some friends!
Maybe you're able to give some head pats there.
I definitely do so.
BAU BAU!
I'm glad you got up for a good time.
Wow, next we have our Question of the Day.
Our Question of the Day is the best!
FUWAMOCO!
I guess I never really thought about it, but is there a reason you don't swear or use a vulgar language?
Do you hold yourself?
You're so bad.
Why is it just not in your nature?
I like and respect that you both don't do it.
BAU BAU!
You know, that's just not FUWAMOCO.
It's just, we're not like that.
We've never been.
We're not that kind of demon dog, you know what I mean?
We've never been, yeah.
And Mama Puppy and papa puppy never said stuff like that.
No, no, no.
And I feel like whenever we hear those kind of things, I feel kind of scary.
You know, it doesn't really make us feel too good and we don't want you to feel like that either.
You know, it's just not us.
It's just weird.
We prefer more fluffy and fuzzy words, you know?
It's just not us, that's why it's weird.
That's just how we feel.
There's nothing deep about it.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU, thank you so much for all your submissions!
You did important for our FUWAMOCO Morning, and we'd like you to be an even bigger clutch!
So please send us, you know, your walks that you go on.
You happen to see Pero, please let us know.
You know, it's a little bit disappointing, but it's important to be in forms.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
You know, just take a look back now.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for sending us your favorite clips subtitled and English over on Twitter.
And if you still haven't yet, please submit the rest of it as you can!
You know, maybe there's another Ruffian that submitted it.
Please still send it to us!
We want to know if you like this one, and we definitely want to share it.
Because there's so many great moments.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
So we hope that you'll join us later this evening for a look back at all the silly things that went on in Holosanto.
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
It's a different time.
P.T.
I forgot.
It's earlier.
Earlier?
It's early!
It's 2AM!
What time is it again?
6PM.
2AM P.T.!
Yes!
So if you want to study some kanji in the middle of the night together with us, that sounds fun to you, please join us!
We'll be doing our best to learn as much Japanese as possible!
Definitely no silly stuff for you.
Aishita desu ne.
FUWAMOCO wa kanji de go no haishuu yarimasu!
Moikai yarimasu!
Revenge!
Revenge desu!
Kondo koso umaku dekiru no kana?
Wakaranai kedo.
Ganbaru shika nain da!
BAU BAU!
And on Saturday, we're gonna be diving into the work of the legendary visual novel Fates Day and Night together with you, Ruffians!
We're gonna go through at least the prologue.
So it's gonna be a bit of a
Ride a ride together!
So let's get really comfy and see just how the world of FF9 starts out.
All together Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Buckle in!
We're ready!
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians who are joining us through the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCODEword!
It's BAU BAU BABY PET!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Achakar!
BAU BAU!
Kumori Senshou!
Dry Toast!
BAU BAU!
Pax!
FUWAMOCO!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!